so I wanted to start I wanted to start
with the line it was like he took my
voice that day just when I was about to
start finding it both times I've seen
the film and I imagine every time I will
re-watch it from here on out that line
will absolutely devastate me so to
highlight some of the good out there can
you name someone that you encountered
early on in your career who who made you
feel seen and supported in the best
possible way so that you could take a
positive step forward when you were
first starting out in this industry yes
yes I was very lucky to have met people
who who
who make me feel you know
um respected and um
met with curiosity and openness and um
and gender equality yeah
I also had different experiences though
I think we all did you know we all had
good and bad experiences to to build on
that then based on having had those
experiences and overcome them is there
anything maybe you personally strive to
do for up-and-coming filmmakers out
there so that they feel the support that
maybe you didn't have as much as you
would have liked when you were First
beginning your career when I first began
began my career I had a very
uncomfortable
um
time of rehearsals with uh with a
colleague a much older colleague and um
and now doing she said uh made me think
back and how privileged I was because I
never experienced abuse in my childhood
I had a healthy childhood you know I
didn't feel incredibly incredibly
dependent on that job I was surrounded
by people who uh made me feel safe and
shared what had happened and helped me
get a liar
and that is very very privileged
um and I truly hope that you know
bringing this story to the screen and
listening to these accounts of the very
very brave women and and some of them
really not being
in the public eye but you know former
ex-assistance
being so happy to maybe have a future in
in that workplace and then sort of have
brutally have been disrupted from it
courageously telling their story I
really hope that this inspires other
people to also
have a conversation and share their
stories and feel uplifted by it and
encouraged
um because this place of isolation is I
think the worst and it still makes me
very emotional if I think of you know
where Zelda Perkins or Laura Madden have
been yeah based on the audience
responses of the two screenings I was at
I have a very very good feeling this
film will have the intended effect I
mean it
um thank you going back to the beginning
here I've I've grown a little obsessed
with this Joe Wright quote someone
shared with me uh recently that that a
director should only take on scripts
that they feel they have a secret about
so I was wondering you know you've got
the incredible reporting here you've got
the real people you're working with a
great script but what was your she said
secret that gave you the confidence that
if you are at the helm of this film you
would be able to bring it to screen in a
way that was uniquely around own I think
my own radar is um
my instinctive reactions to what I read
what I then see in front of my eyes
which is fed also by personal
experiences I think the fact that I was
working most of my life as an actor
um
then turned into directing
[Music]
um the emotional response I had to uh to
so many scenes just gave me
the confidence to
to take it on because it's something to
take on right it's a it's a project like
no other it feels because it's so much
reality in there it's a true story and
not just a true story but a true story
which you know had such an impact and
maybe it's
something very specific that everyone
knows the story so everyone has its own
his own you know projection of what this
movie has to be
um and I think
with the help of so many Fantastic
collaborators
[Music]
um
I I felt very secure and self
confident
about the decisions we had to make how
to film it what to film what not to film
and
the general tonality and
reality about it
all right speaking speaking of how to
actually film and and give us the
visuals for for reporting like showing
news gathering on screen in an i in a
dynamic and also a tension building
manner can be a very very difficult
thing to do so what techniques or tips
did you come up with while making she
said that you might give to another
filmmaker about to tackle their first
film about a vest investigative
journalism well first of all we have to
acknowledge this is almost this is a
genre right journalists you know on the
hand for the truth there are we can name
a lot of titles uh which which make
suspenseful films about journalism and
and I do think this one also serves that
aspect and it is and it I think
it is exciting the more specific it gets
it's uh I I was very happy to you know
learn all about the details and I think
it's a directors uh responsibility to to
uh first of all create emotional
connections to the protagonist and to
really make the audience understand why
this phone call this particular moment
is so very important for them right and
to stay connected with even though it's
very Grand work which we see but I find
it always very interesting to learn the
specifics about other people's workplace
and of course we wanted to portray this
particular workplace with accuracy and
yeah truth with that in mind was there
any like teeny tiny detail in the
process of getting this story out there
that I don't know maybe was deemed like
too small and not worthy of the final
feature film but even though it was a
small detail you knew it was important
and you wanted it to have some screen
time
yeah there were several moments we um we
created through the making
so for instance which is uh the humor
the humor part with Ron and and and
Jody you know this this little
this little Humoresque understanding
um to yeah that that was something you
know the actors very much brought and
then there was um
there was uh another moment that I truly
wanted to see Zelda
coming back from her years in Guatemala
coming back and getting out of the car
and looking
around herself in the in London and
being back yeah that was also a moment
which was important to me and we just
stole that chart and made it happen uh
what you wound up with here is really
something else I could talk to you about
it all day but they will not let me so I
will say huge huge congratulations and I
can't wait to be talking about this
movie for many weeks to come and then
well beyond oh thank you thank you so
much